trois nouveaux membres dans les rangs de
l'opposition brise pas brit-brit se voir
un métairie et patrick chanteurs ont
rejoint le groupe ensemble avant son pur
plaisir affiliés à la république en
marche
une décision annoncée est expliqué en
début de conseil municipal
ça fait plus de deux ans que nous
lançons des alertes sur un certain
nombre de dérives que ce soit des
dérivants en termes de gestion des
dérives en termes d'orientation
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur les
priorités qui ont été choisis par
exemple dans le mode de fonctionnement
c'est qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
main sur le choix des travaux qui sont
faits dans les rues nous n'avons pas la
main sur le contrôle de la voirie nous
n'avons pas la main sur un certain
nombre de priorisation des actions ou
des grands projets qui sont faits or les
plaisirs - attendent ce genre de
priorité un petit exemple on fait un
certain nombre de travaux dans le parc
du château
alors qu'on attend des pistes cyclables
ces trois démissions de quoi lancer les
élections municipales 2020 à plaisir
surprise pas trop vraiment plus tôt je
dirais une confirmation est bien de dan
opportunisme qui me semble évident parce
que quand on partage cinq ans et demi
des projets communs quand on travaille
ensemble pendant cinq ans et demi je
peux que m'interroger je dirais sur les
vrais fondamentaux d'une démission comme
celle ci à quelques mois des élections
nous sommes en proximité permanente des
habitants on entend bien le retour des
habitants sur tout ce que nous avons
fait depuis cinq ans et demi aujourd'hui
on se dit simplement que c'est peut-être
un peu dommage de voir que encore une
fois la politique donne une image comme
celle ci c'est la deuxième démission au
sein de la majorité au cours de ce
mandat plusieurs conseillers municipaux
avaient été démis de leurs fonctions au
sein de la majorité en 2016 sur un
désaccord à propos de fiscalité locale